It's a secret laboratory
that China doesn't want anyone to see.
CNN is the first media outlet
to get this close
to where China actually built its spy
balloons.
A military
helicopter is seen sitting inside
the facility's gates
dispelling any notion that the balloons
are not used for military purposes.
Will Ripley was there and filed
this OUTFRONT investigation.
Hundreds of miles
from Beijing, a place
China doesn't want you to see.
CNN, the first international media
to come here
behind a sea of barbed wire
and security checkpoints.
The base of a blacklisted
balloon manufacturer,
one of six Chinese entities. The U.S.
government sanctioned
after that suspected spy balloon
had just shot it,
shot down,
pulled up and sent to an FBI lab.
Each piece providing more proof.
The U.S.
says this was no weather balloon
deflating denial after denial by Beijing.
China's foreign
ministry calls the whole thing
an accident.
The balloon,
an unmanned civilian air ship.
CNN's search for the truth
behind the balloon
took our team
from the Chinese capital
to Shanxi province,
about 300 miles southwest of Beijing.
Days of digging
and geo location technology
took us down this road
to a place few outsiders have seen.
No international media has ever
come this close.
What did we find
An active industrial complex
with possible ties
to the Chinese military's vast,
highly secretive aerospace program.
Eagles Men,
Aviation Science and Technology, or MRC
blacklisted by the US
Commerce Department.
CNN searched corporate records
suggesting Inmarsat has permits
to develop and manufacture products
for the Chinese military.
The first thing we notice a giant white
dome A closer
look shows the company logo.
And I saw that hunger inside that dome.
A lab
we dug up a 2017 Chinese state
media report
The report says this is where workers
test high
altitude balloons
like the one that flew over the U.S..
Our team spotted
two more massive structures.
They look like giant tents
punctuate teams.
Search of state
media archives
reveals their true purpose.
Huge stealth hangars helping
military choppers evade detection
by prying eyes.
CNN cameras also captured this
what seems to be an assault
helicopter on display.
Diplomacy it.
And listen to this.
That same state media report
never once does it mention meteorology.
It boasts the balloons can carry
multiple detectors.
Communications equipment
used for civilian
and military
surveillance and reconnaissance.
CNN tried to get answers
from all six companies on the U.S.
blacklist.
No response from Inmarsat or the others.
They're not talking about the balloon.
But President Joe Biden is.
I make no apologies
for taking down that balloon.
A suspected spy balloon.
We may never know for sure who made it.
China is sticking to its weather
balloon claim
dismissed by the Pentagon as nothing
but hot air.
This facility is located in
the city of Shanghai.
And by Chinese standards,
it's relatively small, around
3 million people.
But what makes this location
highly significant is that this factory
is very close to a very large Chinese
military base.
And, in fact,
when our team was flying into this city,
they were instructed by the air
crew to close the window
shades on the plane
because they didn't
want the passengers
looking out the window
or taking pictures
of a sensitive military site.
Right next to this balloon factory Erin.